[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today he Ariana
how are you good how are you better than
I deserve what's up I am trying to
figure out how I can get my husband on
the same page with his outof control
spending so that we can have an
emergency fund to fall on and pay off
some of our debts that we have
H well what is this out of control
spending what do you mean my husband
spends over ,000 a month just on phone
games oh phone games like Candy Crush
yeah on his
iPhone oh
wow yes and it's um I found out I look
at our
statements yeah when you say that out
loud does it sound as crazy to you as it
does to me yes like this is this is this
is like illness level MH I'm uh last
year
he I'm sorry you cut out honey what' you
say uh oh thousand you're cutting in and
out you he spent what 14,000 last year
yeah and what what's your household
income apparent your phone has not been
paid
um I can't we're losing most of your
phone here so okay so uh what is your
household income 83000 $83,000 okay are
you somewhere where you can walk and get
a better signal maybe um because we're
losing you about every third word all
right $85,000 how old is your
husband 29 okay all right um I have a
question have a four-year-old daughter I
I have question it's just what I'm
wondering something tells me this is not
the only thing he's overspending on what
else is he spending crazy money
on um his car his his what his car his
car car what's that yeah he has a 91
Volkswagen yeah okay which yeah that
just that just screams money right there
um I'm a stay at-home mom yeah and
I
am the one that pays the bills yeah and
pinch money wherever I can okay um so
that we can get those paid you're you
you guys need to see you need to get
some professional help that's what I'm
thinking too yeah because this is not
$100 uh and he makes
$200,000 and it's over a I know I know
it's 14,000 a year and the money we're
spending on the car too so there's
something I'm sure you're aware of this
or maybe you haven't heard but in
dealing with our phones what we are now
discovering is that a lot of the things
the games and the games have actually
have them they've carefully designed the
games to create a dopamine hit to cause
you to come back again and again and
again they designed these games to be
addictive if you're not aware of that
that's it's very true okay it's also
true for instance the way the videos now
work on slot machines they have
carefully designed those to be addictive
and uh so your husband is involved in an
addictive behavior Loop because if you
just say what he's doing out loud
everyone that hears it except him thinks
cray cray yes they think he's nuts I
know okay and so this is not a money
problem this is you have a husband that
is addicted problem now what do you do
with that if your husband was doing
cocaine if your husband was doing
pornography if your husband was doing
some other form of addiction what would
you do well you would
demand that he get some help and you
would begin to see someone to build
language and a narrative to talk to him
in such a way that he starts to
understand that he's destroying himself
and his family with his
behavior yes because I feel at this
point I'm talking at him this point what
it feels like I'm talking at him oh yeah
you are you're talking to him at it I
just feel like I'm nagging he's glazed
over you're talking to him when he's
drunk yeah you can't talk to a drunk
right it doesn't make any sense and so
but you what you do need to do is sit
down with someone that can give you some
language that says okay this is
terrifying me I have a baby and I feel
like I am in in the house with a cocaine
addict right because you're exhibiting
the exact same behaviors as a cocaine
addict yes and he just spent 700 in the
last three days yeah oh so it's getting
worse my goodness yeah well I mean we've
established he's out of control we don't
need any more we don't need any more
evidence that's established does he
think that there's a problem at all or
when you bring it up is he like no this
is fine this is there's no problem here
he's told me twice that he was going to
disconnect the car from his phone but
then that did not happen yeah well I
mean I'm I promise you I'm not going to
get drunk anymore but I am hanging out
in the bar right yeah right and we do
have a car payment every month and with
what he spent last year we could have
paid off the full balance of what we owe
left yeah but we the car payment is not
your problem the problem is your your
husband is an addict yes and you need to
start treating the situation like your
hair is on fire okay with lots of
urgency and so are you guys by chance in
a good
church um no we're not who is in his
life that can talk to him that will
listen to him it's not you it's
definitely not me
um I have I think that we'd have to hire
somebody that doesn't know us because he
doesn't have a Father Figure or a mother
that he'll listen to so you you need to
you need to say honey I'm going to
marriage counseling because I'm afraid
our marriage is going to end because I'm
terrified that I'm married to an addict
you are completely out of control I'm
going to go see a marriage counselor to
try to save our marriage I hope you'll
come okay and set an appointment and go
okay regardless of whether he goes or
not you go without him okay and have
that person start to teach you how to
speak to an addict to give you any
possibility of getting through the fog
of this into his brain and he remembers
that he's a husband and a father more
than he is a game player on a freaking
iPhone right I think he defies it
because he works so much I don't care
how much he works it doesn't mean you
don't just because you work a lot
doesn't mean you get to do cocaine oh
than sorry that's not how this works I
think his not a tradeoff here I think if
I were in her shoes his phone would
suddenly go missing tonight you think it
would just look at you it's almost like
it ended up in the river and no one
knows how it got there I have no idea
where it is you know after I dropped it
out of the car doing 95 I have no idea
what happened to that pH exactly it's
somewhere between one of those mile
markers back there I know no idea but
he'll have another one by morning if
he's not well that's true this is the
Ramsey Show